hi i'm jacksepticeye and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
a lot of people have a lot of very wrong
information about me but believe it
anyway because it's on the internet
forever
[Music]
why jacksepticeye a question many people
have asked i have no idea why the
jacksepticeye should be the real
question am i allowed to swear here why
is jacksepticeye famous i don't know
the fact that all of you are googling
this proves that as well none of us know
it's an enigma i uploaded videos for
some reason people start watching i'm
very grateful for it but i have no idea
an irish accent goes a long way why does
jacksepticeye not drive come on
what is this i don't drive because i
don't want to conform to the rest of you
sheep i grew up in a small town i didn't
need to drive to get anywhere i live in
brighton now in england public transport
is amazing you people in america should
really try it out i'll do it eventually
i'll make like a whole
documentary about it and sell it to
somebody why did jacksepticeye change
his name what did i change my name from
i mean i'm sean mclaughlin sean is
interchangeable with jack in ireland
when i was in school i got hit in the
eye and it cut open and it bled and then
it got infected and my friend called me
jacksepticeye
i'll hold for applause why are
jacksepticeyes nails black i know i
haven't cleaned them in a while but
don't get that on camera i painted my
nails black like once in a couple of
videos and everyone freaked out about it
and wondered why my nails were black
i don't know am i allowed to throw this
at somebody
what is jacksepticeye's accent irish
from the county awfully into midlands
ireland where a bunch of nobodies go and
everyone lives in debac what does
jacksepticeye say in his intro top of
the morning to you ladies but it's it's
more of a time of the morning to you
ladies
sorry what time does jacksepticeye
upload whenever i feel like it it's
usually around like 5 p.m my time i went
for five years when i started off my
youtube channel uploading twice a day
every single day without missing a
single upload what is jacksepticeye's
least viewed video
that's a good question i
don't know it's probably something like
really early on like
crisis 3
multiplayer
two-part gamepl but he's a great cat
he's lovely what does jacksepticeye's
tattoo mean
which one
sort of an aficionado this one
is from shadow of the colossus which was
my favorite game growing up this was the
first game i played that like changed my
opinion of games but then i got this one
which is now my favorite game which is
bloodborne i have this one as well which
is from arrival a lot of people think
it's a coffee stain because i have a
coffee company but it's not jack's have
the guy who is he i feel like we're all
jacksepticeye it's like a state of mind
i'm a loudmouthed irishman from the
middle of nowhere that no one ever knows
where it's from it got very lucky and
uploaded my voice to the internet and
people start listening it's probably the
swearing and the accent though who does
jacksepticeye play as in free guy thank
you for putting free guy on this and
making me feel like a big time actor
thank you i play myself in free guy when
i talked to sean levy about the role
he wanted youtubers and streamers and
creators in it who play video games and
i got to be in it as myself and you see
my name written in it funny story if you
look at the url when i show up on screen
jacksepticeye is spelled wrong who does
jacksepticeye play among us that doesn't
make any sense i
just play among us i'm bad at it but i
played with a lot of different people or
have played does anyone play among us
anymore i'll i'll switch it up keep you
on your toes who inspired jacksepticeye
i think i got inspired by a lot of
people um i've always watched like
movies and stuff growing up as a kid and
when i was at home when i was a child i
was the youngest in a family of seven
people so i was always cracking jokes
and i was always making people laugh and
trying to like cut the tension but when
it came to like youtube stuff i think
like the people who were all doing it
back then like smosh ryan higa
markiplier had just started um i was
watching some of his stuff just all the
greats who were starting it at that
point the person who really made me do
it is a youtuber called levelcapgaming
who did youtube videos around
battlefield he was the first person i
saw
who i heard did it as a job and i
thought that was the craziest thing ever
and i was like i want to try this out
when did jacksepticeye start his channel
i started the channel technically in
2007. it's been up since then but that
was just to like comment on stuff and
like stuff and watch the stuff that i
really enjoyed i started making videos
like end of 2012. ever since then i've
just kind of been uploading but it was
like 2013 was when i started uploading
properly when did jacksepticeye blow up
everyone thinks it's like the shout out
was when the channel blew up and like
made the whole channel but that is kind
of like a misconception when the shout
out happened it got like i think it was
like 15k subs or like 20k subs in the
first two days and then it just stopped
dead but i think 2016 was when i had
like the biggest boom in my whole career
when will jack accept the guy upload
again i upload it today go watch it when
did jacksepticeye dye his hair i think
that was 2016. mark was doing a
sort of charity event and he was talking
about dying his hair blue and i was like
okay [ __ ] do it i'll dye my hair green
if you do it i've had my hair brown
longer than i've had a green but for
some reason people think my hair has
been green forever there's far more gray
in it than i would like to admit but
it's natural
you see that
fake hair doesn't move like that how do
i contact jacksepticeye you put up a
million dollars i'll do anything for you
if you find out where i live i'm going
to move how to make a jacksepticeye
when one person from a bog loves another
person from a bug they get together in a
swamp and make a sewer child and that
grows up to be a loudmouthed egypt how
many movies has jacksepticeye been in
just the one i've been in a couple of
games and i've done some voices for a
couple of things here and there uh but
for movies i've only ever been in one
how to build jacksepticeye's castle in
minecraft i don't even know how i built
that i built it and then somebody
immediately an hour later uploaded a
video of them building a better one so
poorly how is jacksepticeye you could
have just ended there no one ever asks
that how was your acceptance doing whoa
i'm so sorry i'm doing good i'm here
doing a wired autocomplete interview
it's amazing thank you very much is
jacksep the guy i thought i said a meth
head is jacksepticeye metalhead yes i am
i grew up listening to heavy metal
because of my brother and then i started
playing drums and i've since done
many many things with metal and tulle
are my favorite band is jacksepticeye
coffee good jacksepticeye coffee good
very good drink is jacksepticeye call
jack
yeah is jacksepticeye in human resources
guys
there's so much on the internet that you
can lock up if you're googling if i'm in
human resources we need to have a talk
with your parents because they're not
raising you properly is jacksepticeye
coming to south africa i don't have any
plans i apologize to all of my south
african fans i'll have to look up the
analytics later to see how many of you
there are it's probably like 12. where
was jacksepticeye born and raised i was
born and raised in a small town in a
county awfully called clothing which
only had like 600 people in it and then
i moved to a town near that called
banahar and then i moved to a tiny tiny
tiny town called bali cumber i had no
friends and nobody around me and that's
where i lived in the log cabin where the
jacksepticeye live google maps are you
trying to triangulate my location this
is causing severe anxiety to build up in
me all of a sudden don't find me where
is
jacksepticeye2020 i'm very curious why
anybody's googling that yeah i took a
bunch of breaks i realized that doing
youtube all day every day and working
yourself to the bone and into dust is
not healthy where is jacksepticeye 2021
i've been where i've always been
on youtube making videos people are
probably asking this one because in 2021
was the year my dad passed away so right
after that i took a lot of time off and
to just
grieve first of all but also kind of
like figure out myself
what is jacksepticeye's favorite game i
talked about a little bit used to be
shadowed with colossus it's a very close
second now it was so emotionally
attached to me and i was a depressed 16
year old when i played it but bloodborne
is now my favorite game because it's the
one that i go back to it used to be once
a year and i played like six times a
year what languages can jacksepticeye
speak i barely speak english on the best
of days i wish i spoke irish not many
people in ireland where i was from
actually speak like gaelic irish so i
just never had a chance to practice it
what music does jacksepticeye listen to
when i was a teenager it was sort of
like that snobby behavior of like i'm
into heavy metal and i i kind of had
like a high and mighty attitude about
music because i played drums so i
thought i i have better taste than
everybody else i listen to everything
but my my main genre that i listen to is
heavy metal what is jacksepticeye like
in real life i make a lot of jokes in
real life so obnoxious is probably the
answer that i'm boiling this down to
last one does jacksepticeye watch anime
hell yeah who doesn't i love voice
acting first of all it's one of my
favorite things and it's one of the
things that got me into like uh video
games when i was a kid and i think anime
is like some of the upper echelon of
voice acting does jacksepticeye have
gray hair yes i i've had gray hair since
i was 16. i've been kind of like trying
to figure out why and i realized life is
difficult
and from a very young age i understood
that and the stresses of life kicked in
quick does jacksepticeye have a podcast
no but i i've always kind of wanted to
do one maybe like a narrative driven
thing i've like a ton of ideas for a
podcast that maybe i could do so if
people are googling it that means they
want it hand jacksepticeye sing dance be
a lover boyfriend husband play drums oh
that's much different
uh yeah i can i'm not nearly as good as
i used to be but my feet can fly they're
they're fast boys last question guys
give it up for last question a lot of
pressure on this one can jacksepticeye
age
you age all the time you're growing
evolving your cells are dividing and
they can only do it a certain amount of
times and we're all going to die
eventually
thanks for having me guys
who'd you think about those searches for
any that surprised you
a lot of them are dumber than i thought
they would be come on guys we're better
than that i thought we got past all this
you